SUPER AGGRESSIVE AND BOOK JUST
CAME OUT.
>> I WANTED TO ASK OBVIOUSLY
ABOUT BOOKER.
YOU TALKED BEFORE ABOUT HIM,
HEY, TAKE THE FIRST SHOT
AVAILABLE.
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS DIALED INTO
THAT AND MORE.
TALK ABOUT THE FIRST HALF THAT
HE HAD.
>> YEAH.
IT WAS ONE OF THOSE DEALS WHERE
HE WAS FEELING IT BUT OUR GUYS
UNDERSTOOD THAT HE WAS FEELING
IT AND SO WE GOT A NUMBER OF
STOPS IN THE FIRST QUARTER.
I MEAN, THEY ONLY SCORED 14
POINTS, SO WE WERE GETTING OUT
AND RUNNING.
AND WE HAD A CONVERSATION AFTER
GAME TWO, I THINK, OR GAME
THREE.
IT WAS GAME THREE, I THINK,
ABOUT THEIR DEFENSE IS SO GOOD
AND THEY SHIFT TO THE BALL SO
WELL.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO -- HE'S NOT
GOING TO GET ANOTHER LOOK AFTER
THE FIRST ONE PRESENTS ITSELF.
AND, SO, THAT WAS -- THAT WAS
THE MENTALITY THAT WE WANTED HIM
TO HAVE AND, YOU KNOW, HE
JUST -- HE'S A GIFTED SCORER.
BUT IT WAS -- YOU KNOW, THE SHOT
MAKING AND THEN THE STOPS ON TOP
OF THAT THAT, YOU KNOW, PROBABLY
DEFLATED THEM A LITTLE BIT IN
THE FIRST HALF.
IT WAS AN IMPRESSIVE FIRST HALF.
I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY POINTS HE
HAD IN THE FIRST HALF.
MAYBE 33 OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
BUT IT WAS A SPECIAL, SPECIAL
NIGHT FOR HIM.
AND TO DO THAT IN A CLOSE-OUT
GAME IS REALLY COOL.
AND, SO, I WAS HAPPY FOR HIM,
HAPPY FOR OUR TEAM AND
CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW, HAPPY TO BE
MOVING ON.
>> ALL RIGHT, MONTE WILLIAMS
AFTER THAT 113-100 WIN.
WHAT CAN YOU SAY SPEAKING TO THE
CONFIDENCE LEVEL OF THIS PHOENIX
TEAM NOW?
>> ANY TIME YOU HAVE CHRIS PAUL,
YOU ARE GOING TO FEEL CONFIDENT.
LISTEN, I WANT TO SAY TWO
THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, DEVIN BOOKER, HE
TOOK A BIG STEP BECAUSE NOW HE'S
LIKE, OKAY, I'M AN ALL STAR.
NOW YOU GET A CHANCE TO SHOW
EVERYBODY RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING LEFT
BUT THE GOOD TEAMS.
SAME THING WITH TRAE YOUNG.
YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
EARLIER.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ASKING ME IN
ATLANTA EVERY WEEK.
WHAT ABOUT TRAE YOUNG?
HE'S NEVER MADE THE PLAYOFFS.
NOT ONLY HAS HE MADE THE
PLAYOFFS, HE MADE THE SERIES.
THAT'S WHEN YOU START GETTING
CREDIT.
THOSE TWO GUYS ARE GETTING THESE
YOUNG KIDS.
I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE LIVING IN PHOENIX, I'M
BEAT OVER THE HEAD ABOUT DeANDRE
.
I WAS SO PROUD OF THAT KID THIS
SERIES.
HE PLAYED GREAT THIS ENTIRE
YOU ALWAYS WANT TO SEE GOOD
PLAYERS BREAKTHROUGH AND BECOME
CONSISTENT, BUT, MAN, TRAE,
DEVIN AND AIDEN, YOU KNOW, HOW
IS HE GOING TO DO AGAINST
ANTHONY DAVIS?
AND ANTHONY DAVIS WAS -- BUT THE
GAME ONE WAS TO ME, I TOLD YOU,
GAME ONE WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT
OF THIS SERIES.
BUT GAME ONE THEY SET THE TONE.
BUT, MAN, I'M HAPPY FOR MY CITY
AND MY DREAM OF.
>> DEVIN BOOKER HAD 47 POINTS IN
THIS GAME.
WHERE DOES THAT RANK IN PLAYOFF
PERFORMANCES IN POINTS TOTALS?
SLEEPY HAD 51.
A.I. 48.
THEN YOU G